welcome to the show everybody I am
Keegan I am Jordan and this is t appeal
thank you yes
Jordan and I are we're biracial yes half
black half white and because of that we
find ourselves particularly adept at
lying because on a daily basis we have
to adjust our blackness I mean I know
there's many reasons we do that Mia to
to terrify white people yes that's one
of the main reasons you know with the
way that we sound the way that we
actually talk we're not intimidating
anybody
oh no we sound very white we sound
whiter than the black dude in college a
cappella group oh yes we sound whiter
than Mitt Romney in a snowstorm that's
the reason when we're around other
brothers and sisters you will see us you
know you've gotta just wanna dial it up
a little see you know what I'm talking
about but oh you know you know you know
I know what you're talking about
no I know what you know I know what you
talking about man
because you never you never want to be
the whitest sounding black guy in a room
you put five white talking black guys in
the same room you come back in an hour
it's gonna be like ladysmith black
mambazo
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]